Hình tới 2 giờ ngày 12 hằng sau theo trên thông địa phương, hơn 2 trong người đã được sang nhận thiệt mạng và một hành khác môi ghế mùi một a được kêu sống trong vụ dời mại bài bói mình bây tạm mấy dreamliner của hàng A, India tại Amée đã bắt, hình độ.
Trong mại bây thân dọng chỉ giả tới gần 2 trong năm 2019 của hàng bói mình, Mà số hiệu A, e một bài mô trở theo 2 trong 12 hằng người của 2 trong 7 hành khác và 2 thành viên phía nguồn.
Gặp nạn chỉ vài phút sau khi cất cảnh trong hàng trình đến sân bài gắn quách của lần đồn theo tổng cụ hàng không dần dụng ở nổ.
Tổ bài đã phát hiện hiệu hình cấp trước khi mới lạc với đại kệm xác của 6.
Mại bây giờ xo số 1 tí tục xa xin viên, gần sân bài A mê đã bắt, vây ra của nổ lấn và trải giới dội.
Bào trùng của vực mời khỏi đen dài đặc, theo trên thông địa phương, một số thi thể được tìm thấy tạm chường thuộc về những người có mặt trong tuần nhá khi tài nạn xây ra.
Ngay trong chiều của Ngài, tổ tổn an đồ nạn đồ an mô đi đã yêu cầu vụ chường hàng không dần dụng và vụ chường nở vụ.
Cần chường đến hiện chường trước tiếp chỉ đạo công tắt kêu hộ và hỗ trợ cả nạn nhăn.
Công tắt kêu nạn đang được chình khác với hàng chục xe kêu thường và được lượng kêu hả.
Vì nhân tài nạn chưa được xa đi, điều tra đã được tế hành.
Fiat an cho biết đau phố hợp với chính phủ an đồ để sắp mình thông tin và hỗ trợ công dân an trên trên bài.
Trong khi sân bài gắn quách tuyên bố sẽ sản hỗ trợ hộ cần được cảnh thiết.
Thủ đường an kêu stammer và ngoài trường đe vị lạm mi đã dưới lời chiếc vôn và cảm kết vô chợ cả nạn nhăn.
Lánh đạo các khu ra cũng đã dưới lời chiếc vôn đồ.
Dưới lỡ từ Fly Radaa sân nhận mài bay thủ dòng bố yên bài tạm bay dream lineer
Một trong những dòng mài bay thần dọc, hiện đạo nhất của bố yên.
Đây cũng là hỗ tay nạn trên gồi đầu tiên, liên quan đến dòng mài bay nãy kể tự khi được lượng bố khai thác.
Tất cả đoàn hàng không cũng nghĩ cho biết đăng thủ thật thông tin và chưa đưa ra mình rõ chính thức.
Ngày sạch thông tin để bố tay nát, cô phía bố yên giả mạnh bởi phía tạm phân chăm trong phía n造 việc chân dẫn mật gửa
và mi xuống còn một chăm chỉ bị bởi bà đồ là mi một cô phíau.